c'est bien un jour je reçois un message
sur facebook sur messenger privé qui me
propose de participer à un tel x alors
moi je connaissais pas je savais pas ce
que ça voulait dire tedx alors bien sûr
j'ai été voir mon frère william
j'ai appelé mon frère je lui dit mme
petit c'est quoi c'est quoi c'est quoi
un teddy que ça veut dire quoi bon mon
frère il connaît plein de choses donc je
suis à me demander
il voit le message et il me dit mais si
bien sûr il faut y aller il faut que tu
essaies il faut que tu participes tu
seras fier au cook est ok je lui ai
répondu mais d'abord tu m'expliquer ce
qu'est un tedx donc il m'a montré
différentes vidéos de ses conférences et
plus j'avançais plus j'étais à la fois
impressionné mes angoisses et je savais
pas si je devais répondre parce que je
ne savais pas si j'étais capable de
participer
donc j'ai hésité et puis ben voilà ce
soir me voilà ici
alors merci
dans notre famille nous sommes quatre
mamans mon pain et mon papa mon grand
frère et moi moi je suis le seul en
france où tous les soirs et depuis que
je suis petit tous les soirs au moment
du repas quand nous dînons en famille
souvent mon père me fait toujours un peu
des blagues mais me fais des blagues
d'entendants alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire des blagues dans tendance c'est à
dire c'est des jeux de mots ces deux
mots qui vont se raisonner ensemble
qu'ils vont faire oui réseaunance mais
c'est des jeunes beaux et souvent je
mets 10 minutes pour comprendre
ok quelle était la blague bon alors
souvent j'ai demandé à mon père mais
pourquoi est ce que tu me fais des
blagues d'antan dans ces des blagues
d'entendants il m'a répondu parce que tu
dois tu va grandir et tu va avancer dans
le monde d'entendants donc il faut que
tu ta propre riz la culture des
entendants vie ok d'accord mais tu fais
toujours ses blagues pourquoi pourquoi
ça
parce que tu grandis et en effet tu vas
vivre tu vas avoir une vie d'adulte une
vie active tu vas travailler tu seras en
entreprise et donc évidemment tu seras
au milieu du lac du monde des entendants
il faut que tu sois vous pas que tu sois
perdu face à la culture des entendants
donc voilà voilà la raison pour laquelle
chaque soir il me faisait une blague
n'entendant plus j'ai grandi plus j'ai
compris de choses et j'ai été bon oui
voilà dans la culture entendantes l'a
découvert et aujourd'hui je voc
tranquillement de la culture des
personnes sourdes à la culture en
entente il y à une fois on était en
voyage on est en voiture
et puis je vois à une station d'essence
on s'arrête à une station d'essence et
je regarde autour de moi et je vois je
vois le mot diesel et je pense je me
rappelle à ça me fait penser à un
comédien un acteur célèbre qui s'appelle
vinh diesel et je me tiens peut-être on
peut faire un jeu de mots avec ça alors
puisque ça me fait penser
donc je demande à mon père je dis est ce
que tu pourrais faire un jeu de mot avec
sa d'accord essaye de trouver avec
diesel et vin diesel
moi j'essaie de réfléchir en plus ce
qu'est ce qu'on pouvait bien faire même
si j'avais l'idée qu'on pouvait même
impossible et mon père en deux minutes
il a trouvé il a dit basse ici à gérard
ont fait voir fait voir à quoi voir il
m'a dit ben toi tu prends quoi comme
gasoil comme essence devine du diesel et
voilà et avait le bas devine du diesel
de vie diesel ok on y était en deux
minutes mais jeu mais je n'ai quand même
pas très bien compris ce qu'était drôle
ah oui je comprends le système mais
c'est un jeu de mots mais ça fait pas
vraiment sens pour moi donc c'est vrai
que la manière d'appréhender l'humour où
la culture fin sourds et entendants
c'est un peu différent vrai je vous dis
c'est pas la peine moi de me demander de
faire une blague de sorèze que c'est sûr
que vous vous allez vous casser la tête
de la même manière que moi pour enfin
trouver quelque chose de drôle donc
c'est pas la peine ne me demandez pas
peut-être vous vous dites mais alors
avec ces différences de culture et pas
il ya une différence de culture entre
sourds et entendants et peut-être vous
vous demandez si du coup sourds et
entendants peuvent communiquer ensemble
moi je vous réponds bien sûr évidemment
mais ça dépend
situation ça dépend des personnes aussi
alors pour communiquer il ya trois
solutions
la première les interprètes vous pouvez
appeler un interprète pour les
rendez-vous administratif vous avez un
rendez vous important une réunion dans
ces cas là vous faites appel à un
interprète comme là ce soir et un
interprète voilà et c'est une chance
mais bien sûr pour la vie de tous les
jours on va parcourir un interprète si
on a un ami on va pas avoir un
interprète à côté de soi salle suffit
j'ai déjà ma vraiment sur le dos je vais
pas en plus le col est un interprète
tous les jours ensuite c'est il ya des
applications qui existent pour qu'on
puisse communiquer par exemple il existe
l'application à 20 qui traduit en vocal
un texte écrit qui va le traduire de
manière vocale donc par exemple quand on
est en réunion
si une situation de réunion et tout le
monde parle en même temps je peux pas
suivre le temps de voir qui parle je
peux pas moi alors dans ces cas là
l'application va traduire les échanges
en texte et moi je vais pouvoir les lire
si je parle et ça n'est pas compris dans
ces cas là je tape le texte qui va être
transmis de manière vocale
l'application d'un leur transmettre ce
que j'ai écrit de manière vocale
ça c'est une possibilité et en 3e une
solution il y a aussi les nouvelles
technologies qui nous permettent de
communiquer quand donc j'ai vu ça par
rapport à la famille payer que j'ai fait
donc je faisais le rôle de quentin et
après suite à ce film il ya des
personnes qui m'ont reconnu voilà au de
temps en temps et une fois j'étais dans
le métro
il y avait une femme qui s'est assis en
face de moi qui passait son temps à me
regarder de manière un peu étrange
j'ai demandé qu'est ce qu'elle voulait
pas plus mis ça de côté et je les ai vus
sortir de ça de son sac une tablette
ipad et un stylo et elle a commencé à
écrire sur sa tablette pour je la
regardais faire sans savoir ray et puis
elle a levé la tablette
et voilà et j'ai été vraiment
agréablement surprise est surpris et
impressionné parce que je pense qu'en
effet j'avais jamais rencontré deux
personnes sourdes et elle a trouvé cette
solution là même si elle n'était pas le
connaissais pas la langue des signes
pour autant elle s'est permise de
communiquer avec moi j'étais très touché
de ce témoignage là et si elle avait
décidé de parler malgré tout n'oubliez
pas dans métro il ya du bruit je suis
sûr que j'aurais pas compris et je le
serai passé à côté de ce bel échange ale
ces petites gens ce qu elle fasse ça
donc voila vous comprenez bien que il y
a toujours différentes solutions peut
faire appel à un interprète
on peut trouver quelque chose moi si je
veux pas faire appel à un interprète
si je veut draguer quelqu'un je peux pas
ça dépend des situations si je vois par
exemple une belle fille une entente 1 je
vois une belle fille qui me fait
vraiment et que j'ai envie de la draguer
je vais pas sortir en portable elle
sortir l'application havas qui va parler
à ma pas possible ok ou alors je peux
avoir un interprète à côté de moi qui va
répéter tout ce que je vais sortir de
deux jolies ça ce serait pas cool pour
la drague ce serait pas cool sauf si moi
je décide de draguer l'interprète mans
là c'est autre chose
bon jeu dans la rue j'ai déjà remarqué
que quand c'est des pertes fin comme les
gens croisent des personnes qui ont
d'autres handicaps gens en fauteuil
roulant ou aveugles et tout bon les
entendants ils vont quand même n'ont pas
peur approche et puis voilà
communication se fait et semble se faire
de manière assez aisée moi je me demande
toujours pourquoi quand c'est face à moi
les personnes panique et 10 ans mais non
non c'est bon je vais demander quelque
chose à quelqu'un d'autre je sais pas
pourquoi il ya cette réaction là alors
tu vas être plus précis il m'est arrivé
une fois jetés dans la rue je me
promenais il ya une personne entendante
qui est venu me voir et qui m'a donc
montrer son plan et qu'ils étaient
perdus
il m'a dit oui alors c'est par où je
voudrais aller là mais il avait la tête
retournée je ne voyais pas donc j'y
pense je lui ai demandé de se retourner
de se mettre face à moi pour que je
puisse voilà le comprendre je lui dis je
suis sourd je n'ai pas compris ce que
vous pourriez répéter
et je vais lire sur vos lèvres et d'un
coup il a dit à marc c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon il est parti et j'étais un peu
déçu je me suis dit c'est dommage
pourquoi il ya toujours cette réaction
de rejet
comme quoi maintenant mon dieu c'est un
sourd comment je parlais je sais pas
comment je veux et me prendre et qui
partent alors que c'est pas la même
chose avec les autres formes de handicap
la communication se fait il ya moins ce
sentiment de peur et tout ça là c'est
comme si on avait un mur comme si quand
vous voyez il ya un mur et la
communication ne serait pas possible
alors c'est pas votre faute avouée ou
d'accord c'est pas la faute des
entendants vous n'êtes pas les seuls
responsables et coupables c'est pas ce
que je veux dire le sentiment et les
réactions de rejet de peur sont aussi on
lui aussi chez les sourds qui ont peur
de la communication donc je me souviens
une situation en était un match de foot
avec des sauts en jouets on était une
équipe de sourds et puis il ya une
personne un ami entendant qui vient et
qui veut poser une question et qui dit
qu'ils nous demandent s'il peut
participer et jouer et participer au
match de foot et s'exprime en parlant
donc est ce qu a dit non non attends
olala je vais pas pouvoir communiquer
comme on lui répondre et qui a appelé un
autre source sûre qu'ils se savaient
parler en disant est ce que tu peux
venir pour m'aider comme ça tu vas
parler pour ce que j'ai à lui dire et
tout et je me suis pas c'est pareil
j'étais un peu déçu pourquoi il n'y a
pas cet effort
cet effort simple cette volonté de
communiquer en direct
voilà il suffit juste moi je peux lire
sur les lèvres je peux communiquer on
peut communiquer de façon directe sans
passer par un tiers comme j'étais depuis
tout petit mes parents m'ont toujours
dit il faut que tu apprennes à parler il
faut que tu essaies il faut que tu
essayes d'apprendre à parler ils m'ont
jamais dit que c'était obligatoire
c'était un conseil m'ont dit c'est mieux
pour ta vie active pour david plus tard
ok bon j'ai écouté ce conseil
quand j'étais petit je savais pas trop
ce que ça voulait dire parler il faut
que je parle mais ça veut dire quoi par
les ja oui ok d'accord bon ben je vais
apprendre enfin je me sens un peu de
côté
puis le temps a passé et je me suis mis
à apprendre à parler à comprendre ce que
c'était les mots j'ai fini par
comprendre ce que ça voulait dire que
c'était la possibilité utiliser sa voix
dire des mots créer des phrases les
associés pour qu'il ait une structure
cohérente et où et quand j'ai compris le
système j'étais vraiment impressionné
j'ai trouvé beau j'ai eu et j'ai aimé ma
voix j'ai trouvé que c'était beau de
parler alors route peut-être vous vous
dites mais la langue des signes est
jolie peut-être vous dire la même chose
vous vous dites mais la langue leasing
ces baumes à moi je me dis pareil aussi
avec la voix c'est beau et parler c'est
beau et quand j'ai commencé à apprendre
à parler et à comprendre que c'était ça
je suis devenu accro j'ai parlé à tout
le monde j'ai parlé partout je suis
devenu un vrai bavard notamment avec les
gens que je connais bien avec mes
proches il y à la communauté entendante
et la communauté sur moi je peux aller
je peux venir allaient venir dans votre
communauté entendantes comme je peux
vous guide dans ma commune de thé sourde
et je peux passer de l'un à l'autre sans
problème
j'ai compris maintenant que comment
voilà ce qui fait la culture entendant
ce qui fait la culture sourde quelles
sont les particularités de chacune et je
peux vadrouille et oui de l'une à
l'autre sans problème
moi je n'ai pas encore de peu par les
cheveux la page de prendre le temps
qu'il faut pour que je peux comprendre
que je raconte romain ne paient jamais
comme on était intact un jour qui est
possible
merci merci
aussi je voulais vous dire quelque chose
je voulais vous remercier beaucoup pour
pour tout ce que vous m'avez apporté
tout ce que vous m'avez donné comme j'ai
découvert beaucoup de choses sur moi
beaucoup de choses que je ne savais pas
aussi et que je n'aurai pas découvert
ailleurs qu'ici donc ça c'était une
chance je voudrais dire aussi merci à
mon frère aussi à un ami hashmi pardon
hashmi un ami à moi qui a fait notamment
les dessins là qui ont été projetés je
les remercie beaucoup
merci beaucoup merci